it's edited down into a very specific
you know way this is a much different
way that we do film the show it's more
documentary series but do you ever get
and this is just my own experience as
somebody who is in the public eye not
even a fraction of what you are you know
i
it's really hard it's hard to be i mean
people i'm not complaining everybody has
a rough life and [ __ ] happens to the
world [ __ ] happens to everybody yeah but
it's
to you know that you have lenses focused
on you even when you're not the producer
of those lenses right and even
i can't imagine
what it takes even to get up in the
morning and you know you can't just walk
out without being worried about how you
look how you're going to be depicted
there's going to be a camera on you do
you ever say
[ __ ] it i can't do this anymore
um yeah there are days when you just
don't want to be in that you know
on that platform for example and so but
i love spending time at home i love you
know i've never said i don't want to do
this anymore really as a career choice
or as you know my lifestyle i love what
i'm doing and i think we all do i
wouldn't we wouldn't be doing it all
these years later
but yeah we definitely have those
feelings like i don't want to do this
today
is there not a child where you had to
twist their arm a little bit more than
some of the others that really just
wanted to back off and take a break
um yeah i mean that's one of the reasons
why we thought well 20 seasons is great
at e because you know courtney wasn't as
enthusiastic about doing it as much as
you know she was but she was always the
one who had the question in the very
beginning she was like is this really
you know what i want to do there's
always one oh there is that yeah every
bunch i was friends you know what i mean
i was friends with sharon osborne and
she did the show with me they have a
daughter that's never been on camera
doesn't want to be on camera yeah some
people are just more comfortable kendall
and kylie didn't have a choice
so um because they were young but their
role in all of it was they went to
sierra canyon for example school that's
nearby and they would shoot after school
if they felt like it and their homework
was done or on the weekends when they
you know we tried to get them in their
own environment at the stables or
walking the dogs or you know doing their
chores or whatever they had going on and
they were in it very little compared to
the other ones and then they grew
to embrace it but my question is more
about real life real life and that's
what listen thank god
no no no no but i'm saying the hell that
is real life when yeah the [ __ ] that
happens the camera doesn't turn off and
those are the moments when i would go
listen i just need
a second
you know like
the kanye stuff right like at that point
that's shared with the world
i don't know that you would say at that
point it would be hard for me
i think it's really up to
the individual person in our family
who's going through
whatever life throws at them that day
and whatever they're going through and
how comfortable they feel going through
it you know we see every episode before
it's aired right we have total editing
rights and we what we put out in the
world is what we want everybody to see
and so we've made some difficult choices
sometimes when we've said wow this just
happened do we really want to air this
or do we want to you know and we always
choose to keep everything in but i'm not
i'm not talking about even what goes out
i'm talking about in the moment as
you're going right it just seems as a
viewer i'm just saying which is what
makes you better and more authentic than
most people everybody wants to do a
reality show there's a reason why you're
on top and that's because
we sense that it is your reality
yeah when you're going through that i
don't know that i would even
be okay with having a camera around
that's what i'm saying um
i see what you're saying i you know what
it doesn't really occur to us at the
time we've been doing it for so long
it's just your world that it's just our
world and it's how we live our lives and
sometimes the camera's there for a
totally
other reason for example
um
there was uh
a time when chloe uh was dealing with a
whole thing with um
her baby daddy tristan and the cameras
were in her gym at 6 00 a.m right to
film a workout with her sister
and this
started happening at you know 5 30 or 6
in the morning right and you can't make
this stuff up all of the things that
we've gone through you know that have
been captured on camera are because we
lived with these cameras in our lives
for so long it's inevitable that they're
going to catch
you know most of what's going on but i
think that we've also been able to
along the way shine a really
huge bright light on some issues that
have helped a lot of people along the
way at the same time which i'm really
proud of because we're vulnerable
and will show
you know something that maybe most
people would say oh never like yourself
that's exactly what i'm saying that's
amazing to me that you do it i think
it's good i think that's therein lies
your success well because you always
talk about even with mental health
talking about it and erasing the stigma
which is kind of what you're doing for
everyday situations by putting it out
there and there's no shame because at
least someone else in the world has gone
through whatever it is you guys are
going through i think it's just harder
as
the person
going through it to see in that moment
like i don't know if i'd be able to in
that moment but also i'm not used to it
like i don't have cameras in my face
yeah you're talking about chloe so
chloe's sitting there in the gym and
you're shooting a thing and she gets a
call and she finds something out
that is really tough in her life yeah
i would imagine the knee-jerk reaction
for the average person would be okay
hang on a second yeah the cameras get
get out of here get the [ __ ] out of here
i can't deal with this right now right
i'm dealing with life right it doesn't
seem like you guys do that well um
fortunately for for us and as far as a
production value that we're talking
about kim was the one on the end of that
phone call and she's so
smart and professional and brilliant
about that stuff knowing
that at the end of the day if she wanted
to take it out she could
you know what i mean yeah like if this
is so painful for someone at the end of
the day but that process really hasn't
occurred because we all talk about
everything
and
like i said you can't make this [ __ ] up
if you
no tried it's amazing like you can't
like every single week it seems like
something's happening that's either
really
amazing or you know life happens like
you said that throws a curveball and
then it's how you deal with that
curveball you know and that's what i
think is so interesting because so many
people go through a lot of the same
things that we've been through and some
people are really encouraged or inspired
by the way that the girls handle things
which i think is a really great the
feedback that we get is so positive
but then again it's a real mean world
and i think you get a ton of positive
feedback but you must feel
oh you definitely get a lot of hate at
the same time is that not
how are you that's annoying well you
know listen i told the girls in the very
beginning you just can't read all the
comments and the negative the negativity
or the bullies or the trolls and you
know all the negative stuff that comes
along with this job you really do have
to have thick skin
[Music]
you